it's incredible and such an honor
honestly Elisabeth Moss and her
Handmaid's Tale co-stars are sharing
their reactions to women using the
iconic red costume to protest for
women's rights to see that there's this
one costume this one look that if you
take one look at you know what that
person is fighting for you know what's
you know whose side they're on and you
know what they believe in that had to
have a visual representation like that
there are very few things that that can
do and that's what I get to put on every
day that is pretty cool like that I get
to wear that at work and I feel very
kind of honored to do that if I'm going
to change things I'm going to need
allies I just spent boots bumps the
minute you said that I'm so grateful to
them to think that it could step outside
of a source of entertainment if you will
on to the street it's so gratifying and
what a privilege to be part of this and
when I see it I'm sick of it just bow
down and gratitude to them it's
incredible and beautiful we're not gonna
have the strength to get out there and
stand up in the face of it now that it's
become this kind of symbol of resistance
and the symbol of that women are not we
are not going to Gilead we are not
turning into the Handmaid's Tale we
refuse to let it happen we are paying
attention we're here showing you in a
physical symbol bonnet and red robes
you can't break us those women inspired
me so the fact that they're out there
they're actually I'm an actor I'm doing
a TV show these women are actually on
the front lines they're actually doing
the work
and I get inspired by them wearing the
costume
[Music]